notamment avec ce fameux Cyprien il m'a
fait vivre des moments pas super sympas
que j'avais vécu quand j'étais petit
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Jordan Deluxe alias
Jordan Guinel je viens de Bretagne dans
le 35 une petite ville qui s'appelle un
Romilly alors enfance compliqué
complications
parce que bon alors je suis dans une
famille franchement tout se passe bien
mon père ma mère papa gardien de
déchetterie mais pas super facile de
d'assumer ça quand tu es à l'école mais
bon je trouvais des petites des petits
trucs pour dire oui oui il s'occupe
d'espace vert des trucs comme ça maman
informaticienne l'école un problème
parce que donc au début ça se passait
bien et puis très vite ça va il va se
poser un problème c'est quand je vais
passer au lycée j'arrive dans un lycée
qui s'appelle lycée de la salle et alors
là c'est un peu le l'horreur quoi c'est
là je suis passé d'un lycée d'un collège
où tout se passait bien parce que c'est
un petit collège en Bretagne plutôt
bienveillant et tout et je suis arrivé
dans un lycée à Rennes donc césure déjà
les gens de Rennes tout ça c'était une
autre histoire et je me suis senti très
vite rejeté bah je me sentais différent
je sais pas
je viens de le dire là tu vois c'est un
truc ça me ça me touche me change
j'arrive pas d'amis quoi vraiment puis
après ça a été compliqué parce que je
sais pas pourquoi je n'intéressais pas
les gens qui étaient autour de moi je
m'inventais quelques petites vies à
droite à gauche pour rester dans
l'intéresser quelques-uns mais très vite
il se rendaient compte que ses défauts
donc du coup je perdais des amis que je
venais de me créer et ce qui a été
compliqué c'est que j'ai été prise comme
comme une bête de foire quoi à l'école
et très vite on on m'a attaqué quoi ça
sent vraiment de raison parce que
j'aimais bien m'habiller avec des petits
costumes tout ça je me suis dit comme
CRM je vais essayer de m'habiller classe
et j'ai toujours aimé ça en vrai et
c'était un peu la mode des Baggies et la
mode des Baggies bon à tous les mecs un
peu avec des grands pantalons qui
tombaient machin et tout et moi je sais
vraiment en l'occurrence différent et un
jour j'ai commencé je me suis dit bon
faut que je trouve une combine pour
pouvoir me faire des potes parce que je
ça finit vraiment je le [__] en l'air
ce sera plus simple quoi et j'ai
commencé à je me souviens je j'avais un
groupe et je donnais un dessert à la
cantine pour manger avec quelqu'un
ça c'est un souvenir je me sentais
tellement seule que je me disais il faut
que je trouve une combine pour et il y
en avait quelques-uns qui avaient
compris et en fait je sautais de ma
gueule quoi comme on avait pas le droit
de prendre deux desserts à la cantine
c'est un truc tout con je m'étais dit je
vais donner ce que ce que je ce que je
mange perdu un peu de poids parce que je
mangeais pratiquement plus rien à la
fois parce que c'était le dessert moi je
trouve une combine pour en avoir deux
fois mais ouais et ça a été très très
compliqué à gérer
j'ai eu ça il y a eu je me souviens
l'histoire des cartables j'allais à
l'école on prenait les cartables je me
paraît 5 minutes je revenais plein de
craie tu sais avec plein de trucs dessus
des trucs connards tu sers à rien alors
ça tu sers à rien c'est pareil aussi
c'est terrible parce que quand on te le
dit toute la journée il y a un matin tu
te réveilles et tu te poses la question
une question qu'il faut surtout pas se
poser c'est cette question est-ce que je
sers à quelque chose ce jour où tu te
poses la question c'est le jour où il
faut vite te remettre en question évite
de trouver un truc parce que sinon tu
fais une connerie quoi moi j'ai pensé
une fois j'ai pensé une fois je me suis
dit je me suis dit ce sera peut-être la
solution quoi
pour être tranquille
déjà pour pas en parler à ma mère ça
fait ma mère venait m'emmener je disais
rien tout le temps c'était tellement
compliqué c'est des souvenirs qui me
reviennent en tête rarement je me fais
un comme ça un débriefing sur mon
enfance j'en parlerai rapidement mais
c'était dur ça c'était très très dur et
ce jour j'ai pensé j'ai pensé à ma mère
j'étais en si je fais ça c'est terrible
quoi
je vais tout mon père je vais tuer ça
sert à quoi quand personne ne t'aime tu
vas à l'école tu dis il y en a encore
pour 5 ans comme ça tu peux pas le dire
à tes parents parce que je vais vous
dire un truc quand vous dit un truc à un
professeur je l'ai fait une fois c'est
la pire des choses en fait c'est une
horreur je l'ai fait j'ai dit un prof je
me fais emmerder c'est insupportable et
tout le lendemain le prof me dit vous
venez vous venez un peu en retard je
vais dire non je dis NON NON faites pas
ça mais si si si la démagogie quoi le
prof qui dit à toutes les cas à ce genre
là ne va pas bien faut se calmer tout ça
a été encore pire derrière je voulais
pas faire de mal à ma mère puis aussi ma
mère et qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire elle
va être triste ma mère elle prend tout
ça venait je lui dis un truc je voyais
bien si je l'embête avec ça elle voyait
pas parce que j'étais assez malin je lui
cachais bien donc je me suis dit vaut
mieux que je réalise mon père lui est
plus dans son monde il a un garage il
s'occupe de tout ce qui est ces outils
répare des tronçonneuses enfin voilà il
est dans un autre monde mon père c'est
une bouffée d'oxygène aussi parce que
c'est tout autre ma mère est beaucoup
plus comment dire s'occupe de regarde
elle sent dès que ça va mal tout ça donc
c'est plus dur de cacher à la maman ma
mère elle l'a su parce qu'un jour j'ai
fait une interview sur un papier et le
magazine est sorti elle m'a appelé en
pleurant en me disant mais qu'est-ce que
ce que tu as dit c'est vrai ce que tu as
dit c'est vrai je dis maman je t'ai pas
tout raconté tout et ça ça lui fait de
la peine que je lui dise pas mais et si
vous dire ça me détruit votre vie mais
vous imaginez même pas à quel point et
puis en pensant à ça je me suis foutu
dans les toutes les émissions de télé
qui avait Mireille Dumas Vie privée vie
publique je regardais Morandini je
regardais marc-olivie et ça m'a
intéressé les gens qui avaient des vies
qui avaient des des personnalités tout
ça je suis dit ah c'est de ça que j'ai
envie quoi je me suis dit il y a
peut-être qu'un jour je l'ai
rencontrerai ces gens parce qu'il me
fascinaient quoi j'étais content de les
voir je les voyais sur les plateaux de
télé heureux de raconter leur vie dire
que ils étaient comédiens
qu'ils étaient animateur télé j'ai envie
de ça quoi j'avais toujours remarqué
qu'un animateur télé qui avait des gens
qui qui les aimaient quoi parce que à la
télé elle a toujours un public qui vient
de voir qu'il va faire des photos avec
toi et je me suis dit peut-être qu'un
jour ça m'arrivera quoi c'était vraiment
c'était ça mon c'est devenu mon focus
quoi envie de sortir c'est ma thérapie
quoi ce qu'il faut que je monte à Paris
il faut que je parte je me souviens
c'était en train de faire à passer un
bac pro enfin moi c'était une
catastrophe parce que moi l'école je me
dis le seul moyen ce que j'étais dans
une petite ville en Bretagne c'est de
trouver une combine pour m'échapper sur
Paris parce que c'est à Paris tout seul
et j'appelle une émission ça s'appelait
c'est quoi ce bordel c'était sur Europe
1 avec Laurent Baffie Laurent Baffie
avec des candidats et il y avait un
téléphone à gagner et donc c'est
candidats passaient les uns après les
autres au téléphone il devait chanter
une chanson pendant une heure et ben si
des prenez de temps en temps au
téléphone et j'appelle et le mec me fait
bon Jordan c'est bon vous allez passer
on va vous mettre dans l'émission
tellement heureux tellement fière il y
avait une chanson à faire je me souviens
c'était oh mon bateau pendant une heure
j'ai chanté ça au téléphone et reprenait
par intermittence Laurent Baffie et à la
fin de l'émission donc du coup il me dit
bon Jordan bah écoute tu as bien chanté
mais c'était nul donc tu as perdu et
c'est la concurrente qui a gagné le
téléphone et là je me dis ah non je sais
pas pourquoi non non je dis non et là en
fait il m'a fait le plus beau cadeau du
monde Laurent Baffie en disant ça parce
que j'ai répondu je m'en souviens très
bien j'ai dit ah ouais mais si j'ai
perdu ce moment-là est-ce que j'ai
quelque chose en contrepartie il m'a dit
bah non suivant contrepartie je dis bah
c'est simple je dis soit tu m'offres le
téléphone et tu reviens sur toi tu viens
de dire ou soit je viens faire une
chronique à Europe 1 la semaine
prochaine parce que moi c'est mon rêve
de faire de la radio et là bah film fait
ah bah si tu as des couilles viens la
semaine prochaine petit [__] je me
souviens très bien ce qu'il m'a dit
parce que ça va tu parles comme ça et là
je descends je dis à ma mère maman
la semaine prochaine ma mère elle
comprend pas j'avais chanté pendant une
heure un truc je me retrouve dans le
public avec ma petite chronique comme je
le regarde je regarde l'émission j'étais
quand même content mais bon je vais
aller dans la tête de passer à l'antenne
et là en plein milieu d'émission m'en
souviens très bien il y avait Laurent
Baffie il y avait Geneviève de Fontenay
les frères Bogdanoff et là il me fait ah
au fait il y a un petit [__] qui a
appelé la semaine dernière je fais c'est
moi c'est moi le petit ton cul j'étais
tellement content oui je me regarde tout
le monde
allez tu as fait le malin là bah viens
la faire ta chronique de merde et alors
là ah c'était magnifique je me suis levé
depuis que j'ai été je me suis retrouvé
imaginez-vous à côté de Julien de
Fontenay les frères Bogdanov bah si en
face c'était magique quoi j'ai fait ma
chronique du truc à la con et puis à la
fin je repars et puis voilà ça s'arrête
fais les photos bah si et je vais le
voir quand même je dis merci beaucoup
Laurent et je m'approche de lui et je
sens à un moment de rejet et je lui dis
ça va pas il me fait bah non vraiment
été nul à chier quoi et je lui dis bah
c'est pas grave parce que j'ai au moins
fait mon petit sur Europe 1 j'ai vécu
mon rêve quelque part enfin moi j'étais
content il me regarde il fait mais non
je déconne tu as été très bon et tu
feras la télé plus tard ou de la radio
tu verras et là il me prend dans ses
bras et j'étais trop content c'était ça
m'a fait trop plaisir quoi c'est le
compliment que j'attendais surtout d'un
mec comme ma fille qui savait comment il
est et il me fait au fait il y a la [__]
au chapeau qui veut te parler je la [__]
au chapeau c'était de Fontenay parce que
bon
hier c'est un jeu mais bon il l'appelle
comme ça et Geneviève vient me voir on
discute ensemble avec Geneviève de
Fontenay et en discutant Geneviève me
dit ah bah c'était bien chronique machin
moi je suis toujours entendu avec les
gens plus âgés je sais pas pourquoi et
elle me fait bah faudra que tu refasses
un peu de la télé tout ça de la radio
c'est un peu l'époque Geneviève faisait
plein de plateaux et tout et je lui fais
ah oui ça serait bien que tu pourrais
être mon petit filleul toi hein mon
filleul de télé je vais t'aider je vais
te ta marraine de télé je dis ah bah oui
bah avec grand plaisir Geneviève et là
elle me donne son numéro de portable
alors là sur un papier sur un stylo et
elle note son portable et je fais [__]
j'ai le numéro de Geneviève de Fontenay
et puis je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
un jour on m'appelle et on me dit
bonjour
on voudrait vous proposer de travailler
avec vous sur sur NRJ12 il y a une
émission qui va se lancer qui s'appelle
le 12 info de Cyprien avec Cyprien et
Maxime Muscat je suis amont est-ce que
vous voulez être stagiaire oui bien sûr
mais bien sûr je sais pas ce qu'elle
avait fait genevièvement j'ai fait un an
de stage
fallait pas que ça fasse plus longtemps
parce que je m'étendrais pas sur lui
mais voilà c'est il m'a fait vivre des
moments pas super sympas que j'avais
vécu quand j'étais petit et voilà je
pense pas qu'il pensait qu'un jour je
ferai un peu de télé ou quoi que ce soit
mais ça pas été facile non plus
notamment avec ce fameux Cyprien je
rencontre un jour une fille qui
s'appelait Valérie et qui me présente le
producteur de Mistral le producteur de
Mistral production et Mistral il
produisait Intervilles vous allez faire
les 50 ans un jour je fais le truc
d'intervil avec l'aurore tufel c'est à
l'époque un des chroniqueurs de
Jean-Marc Morandini et qui avait et qui
était sur voltage se passe quelque temps
le stage s'arrête et là pendant les
vacances Laurent as-tu fait le m'appelle
il me dit Jordan je cherche un voltage
man j'ai un voltage manque c'est ça il
fait c'est un mec qui va dans la rue et
comprend à l'antenne en direct et puis
qui commence à poser des questions aux
gens qui fait gagner de l'argent ça et
au bout du deuxième mois je vais appeler
donc voltage man il y a le patron de de
voltage qui aime pas il fait Jordan on
va se séparer de Laurent et on va
remonter une équipe autour de toi et je
me souviens très bien du contrat ils me
font Jordan à la rentrée donc tu
t'appelleras toujours
voltage manager
je me disais mais attends ça me couvert
toute ma vie il faut pas que je regarde
ce prénom là et donc un jour tes deux
jours après il va voir ça je vais dans
un McDo et je vais dans la tête de me
trouver un nom je me retrouve dans un
McDo et là il y a une meuf qui arrive
qui ronce à faire lire les et la meuf
elle est servi comme dans un restaurant
et alors celui-là c'est le Big Mac c'est
un no Besteller machin et tout ça
d'accord ok et puis arrive le Deluxe le
Royal de Luxe et la meuf elle arrive
elle me dit et celui-ci c'est un
indémodable betceller et restera
toujours à la carte et c'est le moins
cher le plus populaire chers c'est pas
mal ça pas cher populaire best-seller ça
restera toujours la carte ça me
correspondait bien et il me dit c'est
royal de Luxe j'ai dit Deluxe c'est pas
mal comme non plus tout le monde connaît
avec forcement sandwich et puis je dis
si je mets une petite particule ça fait
deux luxe ça fait comme si j'étais un
peu noble et je dis moi qu'un
j'adorais m'habiller en costume je dis
ça c'est pas mal ce sera Jordan
j'ai commencé à faire mes émissions ça a
bien marché j'ai fait huit ans sur
voltage et à la fin je vais voir mon
patron et je lui fais un petit coup de
bluff je dis bon écoutez patron moi je
vais partir bah ouais c'est comme ça je
suis désolé il me regarde mais tu
voudrais quoi toi je dis bah ce que
j'aimerais bien c'est après l'émission
psychologique un petit truc un peu fun
je pourrais inviter des personnalités
parce que souvenez-vous j'avais toutes
mes tous mes noms personnalités et là il
fait bon bah allez vas-y ok je te mets
une heure après ton émission tu
t'invitera qui tu veux toute façon ça
sera tard et l'audience et baisse le
soir et je vais vous donner un secret
parce que souvent les gens me disent
mais pourquoi vous arrivez à faire dire
des choses aux gens à la radio en
l'occurrence on se faisait picolé les
invités alors et un jour je me souviens
il y avait Chalencon qui était invité et
je pose une question comme ça à la con
je lui dis en fait vous gagnez combien
quand vous faites à faire conclue et
puis me faire oh c'est 1500 euros par
jour mais c'est rien ça effectivement il
est fou parce que moi je te jure je sais
combien gagne mon père ma mère un jour
je remarque Morandini ce que je lui ai
envoyé toujours des messages et des
petits extraits à commencer à mettre sur
son site et il me dit Jordan t'as qu'à
venir un soir après l'émission et il me
fait faire de la télé je vais
le nœud papillon c'est très simple je
regardais les animateurs à télé et
j'adorais les époques où il y avait des
nœuds papillons des gens étaient bien
habillés et j'ai remarqué qu'à la télé
tout le monde s'habillait en débraillé
comme disait mes parents mes
grands-parents et je sais que ma
grand-mère adorait que les gens soient
bien habillés et tout et de Fontenay
Geneviève adorait ça aussi elle disait
toujours Jordan si tu fais de la télé tu
t'habilles bien classe et qu'est-ce
qu'on a les Miss France ils sont ils
sont en quoi en nœud papillon à chaque
fois vous remarquerez c'est rare qui
sont en cravate et je me suis dit mais
le seul chose qui pourra me différencier
c'est le nœud papillon parce qu'en vrai
un mec qui vient à l'antenne il va
mettre une cravate c'est logique où il
va venir et je me suis nœud papillon
c'est trop classe quoi les gens ils
viennent en nœud papillon quand ils
viennent au Festival de Cannes et tout
c'est la tenue par excellence quoi je
dis bah je vais mettre un nœud papillon
pour me différencier et puis le de
papillon ça faisait un peu comme un X
donc ça faisait le Deluxe j'enlève de
luxe en deux papillons je trouvais que
ça tellement drôle parce que c'est le
ying et le yang quoi on peut le dire
j'aurais de luxe le mec il porte un nom
de Burger il est en nœud papillon ça n'a
pas de sens et donc du coup c'est pour
ça j'ai créé ça je voulais créer un
personnage en fait tout simplement donc
j'étais le filleul mais de télé si vous
voulez j'étais le filleul de télé de
Geneviève mais c'était pas son vrai
filleul c'est pas ma tante du tout et
donc du coup en fait pour accéder à
Cyril bon bah il a fallu que je trouve
des trucs parce que c'est très dur de
parler à Cyril parce qu'à l'époque où je
vous parle il était dans les pieds dans
le plat plus ce TPMP c'est l'explosion
de Cyril c'est tout le monde veut
l'approcher des tonnes de personnes qui
approcher j'avais des petites démos que
j'avais faite absolument lui donner et
Geneviève un jour est invité sur Europe
1 et je m'étais renseigné sur l'agenda
j'avais vu parce qu'elle a un petit
agenda ici notre tour ah c'est quoi ça
Europe 1 ah bah c'est Cyril Hanouna je
vais chez lui danse je fais mais je peux
venir avec toi elle me fait bah oui bien
sûr et elle me comment dire elle
m'emmène et
j'ai réussi à rentrer plusieurs c'est
rentré et je ne lui avais par et là je
vois Cyril et je me souviens je
l'attrape en sortant et il était là il
veut savoir mon chéri est très gentil
mais je me suis dit il va il va et je
lui dis il faut que je trouve un truc
pour le pour le retenir je fais ah ben
enchanté je suis le je suis le filleul
de Johnny Hallyday de Fontenay et du
coup tu vois comme ça me faisait un truc
pour lui parler quoi et je fais ah bon
ah c'est bien mon chéri d'accord ok puis
on commence à parler comme ça et tout
évidemment j'ai pas dit filleul de télé
donc je lui ai menti quoi bon mais il
fallait que je trouve mais comme je le
savais très bien qu'avec Thierry Roland
l'histoire j'avais tout ça en tête je me
suis dit il faut que tu trouves une
combine quoi c'était pas vrai mais
c'était pas très faux non plus ben voilà
et donc du coup ça m'a permis de créer
un premier contact ça se trouve si vous
allez continuer à parler à la série pas
eu de soucis mais comme il venait de la
recevoir dans l'émission il sait plus et
c'est plus il est plus resté avec moi
parce que c'est dire c'est quand même le
filleul de Geneviève voilà et il faut
savoir qu'il y a tellement de gens qui
l’arrêtent que il faut trouver un truc
qui l'accroche le série parce que c'est
il part en deux secondes et il avait
raison il va se tape s'est arrêté et
quand d'un stop s'est arrêté on m'a
proposé d'aller sur Télé Star j'ai été
chez Télé Star et de là Telestar je suis
parti chez Télé Loisirs et Télé Loisirs
c'est le groupe que c'est oui et après
je suis arrivé sur C8 parce que pendant
les vacances Cyril m'a appelé un jour je
m'en souviens très très bien c'était à
9h le matin c'est très rare quand il
appelle Cyril Hanouna je vais vous dire
quand il appelle faut répondre et il
m'appelle il me fait au fait Jordan ta
tournée papillon pour la rentrée parce
qu'il était question que je l'ai pas
enfin c'était des négociations il
voulait me l'enlever et en fait après
Cyril on a commencé à envoyer des textos
et je lui ai envoyé des extraits pour
TPMP et c'est comme ça que je suis
arrivé de temps en temps sur TPMP où il
passait des étages Jordan Deluxe machin
machin il faut savoir que Cyril parlent
beaucoup à Jean-Marc Morandini donc tout
ça c'est une c'est vraiment c'est une
famille quoi et il a réalisé mes rêves
ces deux quand même très importante dans
ma vie c'est Jean-Marc Morandini et
Cyril Hanouna c'est une vérité c'est
l'interview qui m'a le plus marqué c'est
l'incario avec Philippe chevalier de
Laspalès parce que je me souviens très
bien que c'est une interview qui a fait
beaucoup de bruit et ça m'a fait de la
peine pour lui en fait il m'a reproché
mais bon je le savais devoir parler de
politique il faut savoir qu'à ce moment
où je fais l'instant de luxe avec
Philippe chevalier je sais très bien
qu'il est très proche de Marine Le Pen
parce que je l'ai vu sur une vidéo sur
Internet sauf que ça a pas été repris
donc du coup je me dis je vais la poser
dans le même émission mais vous doutez
bien que entre une émission sur Internet
qui passe comme ça dans le vent et la
mienne ou ça part directement chez les
loisirs publics Jean-Marc ça forcément
ça fait beaucoup de bruit et je lui pose
cette question je le regarde et je lui
dis Philippe chevalier pour qui allez
vous voter cette année et en plus
c'était les élections enfin bref et il
me dit bon bah moi je suis plus pour
Marine Le Pen et je sais que ça a été
terrible j'ai regretté après parce que
j'ai vraiment là il retravail mais à un
moment il a vraiment pu travailler
pendant un bon bout de temps il a
c'était partout que cette question et
c'est vrai que moi j'ai pas vu le mal je
me suis dit bon comme il l'avait déjà
dit dans une interview mais ça lui a
vraiment fait beaucoup de mal quoi
est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
montre mon téléphone avec tous les gens
qui m'envoient des messages en me disant
Jordan coupe ça s'il te plaît coupe
c'est tous les jours il y a un service
après-vente à gérer je vous jure sur
chez Jordan c'est un truc de malade bien
sûr qu'on coupe des choses on n'a pas le
choix déjà parce que l'invité il vient
il dit des choses et comme c'est une
mission qui est pas en direct on est
obligé de couper des fois des trucs et
je vais vous dire j'ai sauvé la vie de
quelques artistes sincèrement qu'on dit
des choses à l'antenne franchement c'est
c'était chaud et nous on a dit voilà il
faut venir couper même des fois c'est
moi qui ai dit on a qu'on coupe parce
que là on va on va lui tuer sa carrière
parce que les gens se rendent pas compte
je ne sais pas pourquoi il y a des
invités je sais pas pourquoi je pense
parce qu'il parle et je laisse parler
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont en
confiance avec moi en fait il y a des
gens qui déballe des trucs de fou quoi
moi j'ai des gens qui m'ont sorti des
trucs à l'antenne si ça passe ils vont
perdre leur travail quoi ils vont se
faire virer de TF1 France 2 je vous jure
un des animateur très connu des
animatrices très connu dans 10 ans
franchement 10 ans si je suis sur C8 et
que j'ai un prime une fois de temps en
temps je suis ravi quoi arriver à
devenir un animateur que un animateur
que les gens aiment bien et où ils se
disent ah c'était chez Deluxe ah
franchement c'était sympa j'aimerais
bien évoluer un petit peu comme ça quoi
ça sent très kiffer quoi